Der Rasenfunk Kurzpass. 30 Spieltage sind absolviert in der 2. Männer Bundesliga. So langsam spitzt sich alles zu. Sowohl im Aufstiegskampf als auch im Abstiegskampf. Beides wollen wir besprechen hier im Rasenfunk. Ich begrüße euch ganz herzlich hier in diesem Rasenfunk Kurzpass Nr. 202. Mein Name ist Max Jakob Ost. Ich bin der Ed Genetzer auf Twitter und ich freue mich, zwei Gäste hier zu haben, die auch einen Schwerpunkt mitgebracht haben. Meine Güte, da geht es schon gut los. Zum einen Dominik Slišković von T-Online, der Ed, Jasam, Dominik auf Twitter. Hallo Dominik, schön, dass du mal wieder hier bist. Ja, freut mich, dass du hier bist. Mit dir werden wir gleich ein bisschen ausführlicher über den FC Schalke 04 sprechen. Wir haben schon vorab geklärt, du hast eine gute Laune mitgebracht in diese Sendung.
Absolut, Ostern und Auswärtssieg, ich kann mir eigentlich nicht mehr wünschen.
Das ist sehr schön formuliert und ich glaube ganz ähnlich geht es auch Tobias Kröger von transwehrmark.de, der Ed Tobias Kröger auf Twitter seines Zeichens HSV Fan und dem entspricht auch mit nicht nur drei Punkten vom Wochenende ausgestattet, sondern guter Laune und vermutlich schon ein bisschen freudiger Erwartung. Hallo Tobi.
Moin Max, schöne Grüße aus Hamburg, freue mich sehr hier zu sein und ja, ich bin schon sehr aufgeregt auf das DFB-Pokalspiel, auf das wir später wahrscheinlich noch zu sprechen kommen werden.
Da werden wir auf jeden Fall noch drüber sprechen, wenn wir über die Perspektive des HSV reden wollen. Lasst uns gar keine Zeit verlieren, hinein in die Tabelle der 2. Liga der Männer und da führt Schalke 04 Dominik die Tabelle an und konnte seinen Vorsprung ausbauen am Wochenende. Ein 5 zu 2 auswärts in Darmstadt bedeutete nicht nur einen deutlichen Sieg gegen einen direkten Aufstiegskonkurrenten, sondern weil die Verfolger jeweils nicht dreifach punkten konnten, sogar jetzt einen 2-Punkte-Vorsprung auf den 2. Platz und noch wichtiger, einen 3-Punkte-Vorsprung auf den 3. Platz und 5 Punkte sind es sogar schon auf den 1. Nicht-Aufstiegs-Platz bzw. Nicht-Relegationsplatz. Steigen die Schalke jetzt tatsächlich auf, Dominik?
Davon gehe ich jetzt mal schwer aus. Also hättest du mich vor einem halben Jahr, vielleicht auch sogar noch vor 6-7 Wochen gefragt, hätte ich noch ganz anders und abwartender geantwortet. Aber jetzt gehe ich schwer davon aus. Ich habe gestern auch den Tabellenrechner mal durchgespielt und ich will mich selbst etwas in meinem Optimismus bremsen. Aber es sieht ja fast sogar gut aus, dass uns der Aufstieg oder das Schalke 04, der Aufstieg im wunderschönen Sandhausen gelingen könnte. Das würde mir dann für die vielen Dauerkarteninhaber etwas leid tun, weil die HTW-Arena am Hartwald ist ja auch nicht die größte. Aber ja, da würden bestimmt einige den Ausflug auf sich nehmen dann.
Okay, also ich sehe, du bist ein Mann der klaren Aussage, was hat sich denn jetzt unter Mike Büssgens verändert? Ist er derjenige, der durch Handauflegen alle Probleme gelöst hat? Was ist da los bei Schalke?
Ja, wenn das mit dem Handauflegen so einfach wäre, dann hätte er Schalke schon lange kein Problem. Aber Spaß beiseite, ich glaube, was das offensichtlichste ist, ist, dass Mike Büssgens vom 3-5-2 auf ein 4-2-3-1 oder auch ein 4-2-2-2 umgestellt hat, also die Viererkette wieder zurück auf Schalke gebracht hat. Und was, glaube ich, dem ganzen Spiel noch mal sehr viel mehr Qualität gegeben hat, ist, dass er Koita Kura aus Endverteidigung auf die Sechs neben noch einen etwas körperlicheren Sechsern gestellt hat. Dadurch ist das ganze Spiel nach vorne bzw. der Spielaufbau noch mal wertiger geworden. Und das ist, denke ich, auf jeden Fall was, was man Büssgens zuschreiben kann. Ansonsten ist, glaube ich, auch einfach die Kommunikation, die er mit den Spielern pflegt, die jetzt noch mal gewisse Kräfte freigegeben hat, wie man so schön sagt. Das hat man ja auch in den Monaten unter Gramozis immer wieder gehört, dass Büssgens da den größeren Kommunikator gegeben hat innerhalb der Mannschaft. Und wenn jetzt die Mannschaft natürlich auch weiß, so jetzt ist er zumindest interimsweise der Chef. Und jetzt haben seine Worte auch noch mal irgendwie eine größere Wertigkeit, dass das die Mannschaft oder die einzelnen Spieler auch noch mal irgendwie mehr abholt, sei es jetzt im Stolz oder wo auch immer. Aber was mich noch mal irgendwie besonders freut, ist, das ist ja gestern auch bei Twitter und ähnlichen Social-Media ist rumgegangen, dass auch die Spieler, die es dann nicht in den Spielplan, Spieltags-Kader schaffen, auch voll dabei sind. Also gestern zum Beispiel Daco Tchuljnov zuhause Simon Tirode abgefeiert hat. Sehr, sehr lautstark. Ich musste mein Handy erst mal runter korrigieren, weil der Lautstärke als ich das mitgekommen habe. Aber das ist natürlich so, auch was den Fans natürlich irgendwie das Herz öffnet. Und ich glaube dann halt auch so in so einer Trainingswoche, ja, für das eine oder andere lächeln sorgt und den einen oder anderen Steigerungslauf oder ähnliches auch erträglicher macht.
Tobi, was macht das mit dir als HSV-Anhänger, wenn ein Trainerwechsel so gut funktioniert? Eine Mannschaft im April, also generell seit Übernahme von Büsskins, alles gewonnen. Die komplette Schwere scheint weg zu sein bei Schalke. Ich erinnere mich noch an dieses 3 zu 4 gegen Hansa Rostock zu Hause, das letzte Spiel von Gramozis. Seitdem cruist Schalke durch diese Liga und hat jetzt eben wirklich allerbeste Aussichten auf den Aufstieg. Hätte man sich sehr wahrscheinlich beim HSV schon so oft gewünscht. Kannst du da Unterschiede erkennen? Wie ist dein Blick auf Schalke?
Ja, so wie ein guter Trainerwechsel funktioniert, habe ich ja jetzt auch diese Saison leider bei Werder zwischendurch gesehen, die ja nach Ole, nachdem Ole Werner eingestiegen ist, ja auch einen sehr guten Run mit, ich glaube, neun Siegen in Folge hatten. Diese Einstiege natürlich mit diesen Siegesserien sind ja so oder so sehr wichtig und auch gerade in der zweiten Liga, wo es sehr viele, ja ich sag mal, Stolperstellen gibt, wie beispielsweise in Sandhausen, wo fast alle großen Vereine immer Punkte lassen. Und ja, da kann man im Moment auch als Hamburger quasi nur neidisch nach Schalke gucken. Ich muss sagen oder ich muss zustimmen, jetzt unter Büsskins, also da wurden ja sehr viele Stellschrauben auch geändert und meiner Meinung nach auch wirklich die richtigen, wo ich noch in der Hinrunde gesagt habe, das Schalkerspiel hängt viel zu sehr von Uwe Schalke ab. Da war ja unter Gramozis hatte man teilweise das Gefühl, da wird einfach jede Halbfeldflanke über links einfach in den Strafraum gehauen und gehofft, dass irgendwie Terodde an Beikommt und da irgendwie die Dinger reindrückt. Und wenn ich jetzt sehe bei Büsskins, wie er auch Salah sah, den ich als einen der besten Spieler eigentlich in Form betrachte, wie der auf die Strecke gebracht hat und Dominik ja auch schon gesagt hat, mit Itakura ans Mittelfeld ziehen. Also da hat Schalke auf jeden Fall die richtigen Stellschrauben gezogen und auch gedreht. Und ja, was mir bei Schalke jetzt eigentlich auch unter Büsskins gefällt, ist, dass man merkt von außen, dass da so eine gewisse Aufbruchstimmung da ist. Also man hat mit Grammozis auch wegen der defensiven Taktik, dann hat er ja noch quasi die Niederlagenserie aus der Bundesligasaison noch mitgebracht. Da wirkte Schalke immer ein bisschen gehemmt in meinen Augen, dass man sich unsicher war, wie soll man erstens sein eigenes Spiel aufziehen, aber auch so, welches Potenzial haben wir jetzt eigentlich. Und ja, seitdem Grammozis weg ist und zu Büsskins gewechselt wurde, habe ich wirklich das Gefühl, okay, Schalke glaubt jetzt an sich und hat jetzt auch quasi, wenn man jetzt bei dem Flosken bleiben will, die Handbremse gezogen und sieht man ja auch jetzt auch einen Böter, der jetzt auch noch mal jetzt einfach mal ein Dreierpack in Darmstadt macht. Also Schalke ist für mich jetzt eigentlich kaum noch zu stoppen, auch wenn man das Torverhältnis sieht, was eindeutig für Schalke spricht. Also da hat man wahrscheinlich im letzten Moment noch die richtigen Entscheidungen getroffen und von Grammozis zu Büsskins gewechselt. Also da kann man im Moment nur neidisch nach Schalke schauen.
Ja, der Dominik muss aufpassen, dass er nicht ausrutscht vor lauter Öl, was ihm da runtergegriffen für die Kehle. Das ist ja schlicht der Wahnsinn. Also plus 28 ist die Torreferenz von Schalke. Zum Vergleich, Werder und St. Pauli haben plus 15, Darmstadt plus 16. Also das ist schon wirklich sehr, sehr eindeutig. Und ich finde, mit Marius Böter ist hier auch schon ein Name gefallen. Dominik, der ja durchaus so ein bisschen stellvertretend steht für den Erfolg von Schalke 04. Zusammen natürlich mit Simon Terodde, der jetzt bei 24 Saisontoren steht nach 26 Spielen, die er bestritten hat. Also eine absolut fantastische Quote. Mit Böter hat man ja aber dann einen ganz wichtigen Aspekt, wo der Grundstein für diesen möglichen Wiederaufstieg, ich will es jetzt auch nicht beschreien, schon im Sommer gelegt wurde. Wie gefällt dir denn die Kaderzusammenstellung jetzt auch, wo man sieht, welches Potenzial er entfalten kann?
Ja, also Böter hat sich jetzt natürlich mit dem Spiel in Darmstadt noch mal so ein kleines Zweitligadenkmal gesetzt. Da lief ja wirklich alles am Schnürchen. Also einen eigenen Dreierpack geschnürt und ein Tor vorbereitet. Ich habe auch gerade mal geschaut, wie viele Vorlagen er eigentlich insgesamt gegeben hat. Es sind zwölf. Was finde ich für eine hängende Spitze oder eine zweite Spitze, je nachdem, wie so ein Angriff aufgebaut ist bei Schalke, ja auch spielen kann, ist da schon aller Bonheur. Generell die Kaderzusammenstellung war natürlich auch eine Mammut-Aufgabe. Es waren ja fast 50 Zu- und Abgänge, die im Sommer moderiert werden mussten. Und da kann man vor Ruven Schröder, aber auch Peter Knebel, der zum Beispiel Simon Terodde geholt hat, bevor Schröder sein Amt offiziell angetreten hat, auf Schalke geholt hat, nur den Hut vor den beiden ziehen. Und man sieht jetzt eben auch, Tobi hat gerade den Namen Salazar genannt. Das ist auch so ein Spieler, der braucht seine Zeit. Das haben wir vergangene Saison in St. Pauli gesehen, der aber eine unglaubliche Qualität hat. Und wenn man ihn auch richtig einsetzt, was Büssken macht, als eher ein zweiter Zehner mit Drechsler vorne, dann bringt er auch seine Qualität. Also der hat wirklich einen feinen Fuß, der kann schöne Halbfeldflanken, Lops, aber auch mal den Fernschuss ansetzen. Ich glaube, der hätte jetzt auch in Darmstadt mal wieder die Latte geküsst. Hätte ich ihm auch total gegönnt, wäre der reingegangen, weil er gestern bzw. am Ostersonntag ein super Spiel gemacht hat. Von daher kann man da Schröder auch nur beglückwünschen, dass er einen Salah sah, der vom ein oder anderen Bundesligisten, glaube ich, umschwärmt wurde, für Schalke gewinnen konnte und ihn auch vom weiteren Plan, den Schalke mit Schröder und Knebel als sportliche Leitung überzeugen konnte.
Jetzt haben wir ja mit Salah sah schon einen Leihspieler angesprochen. Uwe Schan, ebenfalls geliehen. Etacura, ebenfalls ausgeliehen. Ich bin jetzt nicht genau drin, was Kaufoptionen usw. angeht. Welche Perspektive hat den Schalke mit Blick aufs nächste Jahr?
Salah Sahs Kaufoption wurde ja schon gezogen. Ich glaube, der hat bis 2025 unterschrieben, wenn mich nicht alles täuscht. Du hast Uwe Schan und Etacura angesprochen, beide mit Kaufoptionen ausgestattet. Bei Uwe Schan liegt sie knapp über 2 Millionen, was durchaus machbar wäre bei einem Aufstieg. Bei Etacura liegt sie über 5 Millionen. Das ist schon ein Päckchen, was man dann irgendwie schnüren müsste. Aber Rufin Schröder hat auch schon im Winter quasi gesagt, na ja, er macht sich da eigentlich keine Sorge. Wenn man die Spieler weiter verpflichten möchte, dann findet man Wege. Und selbst wenn es dann halt so ist, dass man sie erstmal einkauft und dann teuer weiterverkauft. Bei Oian sollen ja die Clubs vom Rhein, also Leverkusen und Gladbach, wohl auch schon ein Auge drauf haben. Natürlich wird der Schalker Fan-Säle und natürlich auch dem Trainerteam der sportlichen Leitung wehtun, wenn man so einen Spieler abgeben muss, weil er natürlich eine absolute Qualität über die ganze linke Flanke reinbringt. Aber man muss dann halt auch vor allem als Schalke 04 wirtschaftlich denken. Und wenn man dann quasi für ein Ojan als Gesamtpaket irgendwie zwei bis drei Millionen ausgibt und ihn dann für das Drei, vielleicht sogar Vierfache verkaufen kann, dann muss man sagen, here we go, done deal und Glückwunsch.
Man muss ja auch bei Schalke bedenken, dass man ja auch schon im Winter ein Angebot für Malik Džao hatte von Milan, dass man auch da sagen kann, es gibt ja auch noch einen Spieler im Kader, der auch noch eine hohe Ablöse generieren kann. Sprich, wenn man aufsteigt und sagt, man würde ihn dann verkaufen, das wären dann vielleicht doch die Mittel, die man dann auch gerade nutzen kann, dass man einen Spieler verkauft, den man wahrscheinlich dann auch mit Bauchschmerzen verkaufen würde, aber dann sagt, okay, wir geben einen Spieler ab und holen dafür drei neue Spieler bzw. binden drei Stammkräfte, die wir per Kaufoption halten wollen. Also ich glaube, da ist Schalke eigentlich ganz gut aufgestellt im Moment und hat halt auch noch junge Spieler, die man theoretisch auch noch mal dafür nutzen könnte per Verkauf, um den Kader quasi im größten Sinne zusammenzuhalten.
Ja, mit Schausprich ist ja auf jeden Fall auch interessante Personalien. Also da wurde ja gesprochen, also im zweistelligen Millionenbetrag, dass da ein Angebot aus Milanello eingetrudelt ist, 10 bis 12 Millionen, und Schalke dann abgelehnt hat, was ja auch erst mal ein Machtwort ist von Schröder und Knebel. Wäre natürlich eine Option, klar, dass man ihn jetzt im Sommer dann gehen lässt als Aufstiegskandidaten, als Aufstiegshelden, so. Aber es wäre natürlich auch absolut möglich, dass man ihn davon überzeugt, wir geben dir jetzt noch eine Erstligasaison, wo du dich halt wirklich nochmal beweisen kannst, als absolut unangetasteter Stammspieler und man ihn dann vielleicht sogar zum Winter dann gehen lässt. Also, dass man ihm nur ein bisschen Erstliga-Erfahrung mitgibt auf den Weg. Das ist durchaus möglich und ich kann mir auch gut vorstellen, dass man da nicht, wenn jetzt wieder im Sommer irgendwie zwölf, vielleicht sogar 15 Millionen Angebot eintrudelt, dann sofort zuschlägt. Also da schätze ich Schröder auch als so jemand ein, der dann lieber mal eine Runde, also eine Investitionsrunde aussetzt und ein bisschen pokert.
Lass mal bei diesem Punkt der Finanzierung bleiben, denn da tut sich wirklich Erstaunliches beim FC Schalke 04. Es scheint tatsächlich so zu sein, dass man den gordischen Knoten zumindest schon mal teilweise durchtrennt hat aus Ausgaben reduzieren, Schulden abbauen und dennoch den Wiederaufstieg hoffentlich schaffen aus Sicht aller Schalkerinnen und Schalker. Es sieht zumindest aktuell gut aus. Wie gesagt, ich will es jetzt auch nicht als Fakt schon hinstellen. Aber erklär mir das mal, wie das funktioniert hat. Christina Rühl-Hammers, die Finanzvorständin, hat die Zahlen präsentiert. Ich glaube, im März war das irgendwann. Da konnte man sehen, man hat zwar wieder einen Verlust gemacht, vor allem auch Corona-bedingt, aber mit 18 Millionen Euro schon viel niedriger als die 53 Millionen Euro Verlust im Vorjahr. Aber was mich vor allem wirklich umgehauen hat, war nicht nur, dass man die Verbindlichkeiten reduzieren konnte um 33 Millionen Euro, sondern dass man es geschafft hat, die Personalausgaben von über 80 Millionen Euro auf 20 Millionen Euro runterzubringen. Also eine irre Verkleinerung. Wie ist es denn Rowen Schröder und Sportvorstand Peter Knebel gelungen?
Ja, also man hatte erst mal diese ganzen Großverdiener aus Bundesliga-Zeiten, oder man ist es gelungen, diese ganzen Großverdiener vom, ja nicht vom Hof zu jagen, aber sie freundlich zu verabschieden in allen Herrenländern, also sei es ein Nastasic, ein Aminarit, ein Osankar Baksu, ein Serdar, das waren ja alles Spieler, die also Stammelf-Qualitäten hatten, aber natürlich in der Zweitliga absolut überbezahlt sind und die man zumindest mal von der Gehaltsliste als Leihe oder im Falle von Nastasic, von Serdar, für relativ niedrige Ablösesummen erst mal losgeworden ist und da durch sich ein klein, aber immerhin finanziellen Spielraum auch geschaffen hat, wieder dann eine Zweitliga-Garde aufzubauen, also Spieler wie Ich glaube, es gibt viele, die eben Hita Kura und Salazar Ojan auszuleihen, in Bülter zu holen von Union. Und natürlich gab es sicherlich auch Klauseln, die bei einem Zweitliga-Abstieg gegriffen haben, dass die Gehälter, die in Bundesliga-Zeiten gezahlt wurden, sich minimiert haben. Also mir fällt der Fall Ralf Fehrmann ein, wobei das mit einer Vertragsverlängerung zusammengehangen hat, aber der auf jeden Fall ordentlich Einbüßen hingenommen hat. Also noch immer einer, der Großverdiener ist, aber er hat auf jeden Fall auch einen cut gemacht, einen finanziellen. Man muss echt sagen, wenn man sich jetzt den heutigen Schalker Kader anschaut und den mit der vergangenen Saison vergleicht, ist es eigentlich nur noch Salih Sané, den man nicht von der alten Gehaltsliste bekommen hat, der quasi so ein bisschen noch wahrscheinlich irgendwo im Hinterstübchen von Rufen Schröder weh tut, weil er weiß, dass er eben noch einen Bundesligagehalt kassiert. Aber auch Sané muss man ja sagen, als er dann mal fit war und auch mal seine Spiele bei 90 Minuten gemacht hat, unter anderem in Aue, hat er auch gezeigt, dass er ein absoluter Unterschiedspieler sein kann in der 2.
Liga.
Aber es ist natürlich auch utopisch zu denken, dass man das mit einem Serdar oder Nastasic auch hinbekommette. Also dann hätte man andere Spieler eben nicht verpflichten können. Und dann wären die Finanzen, die Frau Rülhamas vorgestellt hat, auch sicherlich so für Schalker-Verhältnisse fast schon rosig ausgefallen.
Also der Umbruch war natürlich krass. Allein 33 Zugänge, 32 Abgänge, also einmal komplett durchrotiert das ganze Ding. Dann ist man auch noch Gazprom losgeworden. Und hat dafür aber gleich einen Ersatz gefunden mit einem anderen Sponsor bzw. zwei neuen Sponsoren, die in die Bresche gesprungen sind für Gazprom, die nach Anbruch des Ukraine-Krieges nicht mehr weiter Sponsor sein sollten. Das wirkt für mich wie eine Transformation von Schalke 04. Und ehrlicherweise, ich hoffe, dass ich jetzt nicht zu Königsblau male, aber auch wie etwas, was sich ganz viele Fans gewünscht haben für Schalke. Ist das eine richtige Einschätzung der Lage? Siehst du das etwas nüchterner? Ist da mein Blick von draußen zu positiv?
Ich glaube, diese Transformation, wie du es genannt hast, wird dem Verein auch mittelfristig nochmal viel geben. Also allein aus Imagegründen ist es jetzt einfach gut, dass man dieser Altlast Gazprom losgewonnen ist. Und das hat ja sich, ich will nicht sagen angebahnt, aber ich glaube, da schlummert viel noch im inneren Kreis, im inneren königsblauen Kreis, was da vielleicht schon vorab für Überlegungen waren. Also man hat jetzt ja mit Axel Hilfer einen Aufsichtsratsvorsitzenden, der ein klarer Tönnies-Kritiker war, der ja schon mal im Aufsichtsrat auf Schalke saß und mehr oder weniger von der Tönnies Machtklicke rausgemobbt wurde. Unternehmer, der A, also dementsprechend, die die finanzielle wirtschaftliche Komponente mit in den Club reinbringt, aber auch B, einen Sponsor eines Top-Klubs wie FC Chelsea und dementsprechend auch dieses ganze Sponsoring-Themenfeld total gut kennt und der ja auch zum Beispiel den Gedanken eingebracht hat, wir verlieren Gazprom als den großen Hauptsponsor. Lass uns doch aber jetzt versuchen, diese Sponsorenlast, sag ich mal, diese finanzielle Last auf mehrere Schultern zu verteilen. Lass uns doch einen Trikot-Hauptsponsor mit Viva West suchen und lass uns doch zum Beispiel, wie es eben in der Premier League, wo Chelsea auch spielt, gang und gäbe es einen, quasi einen Trainingskleidungssponsor suchen, den Schalke jetzt mit Rewe gefunden hat. Das ist ja auch ein Deal, der, ich bin mir nicht sicher, aber zumindest für mich in der Art neuartig war in der ersten und zweiten Bundesliga. Und das zeigt ja auch, dass Schalke einfach neue Wege denkt und geht dann auch. Und dass man da auch in guten und progressiven Händen ist mit Hefer und Co. im Aufsichtsrat. Und nicht nur, weil diese Altlass-Gasprom jetzt los ist, sondern jetzt auch das Gefühl hat, dass diese ganze patriarchale Struktur, die von Tönnies geprägt wurde, so langsam aber sicher wirklich ad acta gelegt wird auf Schalke.
Ich könnte noch Ewigkeit mit dir über Schalke sprechen. Das ist absolut faszinierend, was in diesem Verein passiert ist. Mit letztlich auch der Gramozis-Entlassung. Aber ich reduziere es jetzt auf eine letzte Frage, weil ansonsten geht der halbe Kurzpass nur dafür drauf. Wird Mike Büssgens eventuell sogar Trainer bleiben?
Nein, davon gehe ich nicht aus. Mike Büssgens hat ja selbst gesagt, er will der Hermann Gerland von Schalke sein. Und genauso wie Hypp Stevens, glaube ich, viermal Schalke Trainer war davon, zweimal Intrimsmäßig oder vielleicht zwei-, dreimal Intrimsmäßig, weiß ich gar nicht mehr. Das war so oft, bringt man alles durcheinander. Aber genauso konnte Bujo, wie er ja genannt, Viertel Schalke auch nicht nein sagen, als man gesagt hat, mach es mal, setz den Loch in Denkmal auf Schalke. Ich muss auch sagen, als Beobachter und auch Fan, weiß ich auch gar nicht, ob ich das überhaupt will, dass Büsskins als Cheftrainer in die Bundesliga geht mit Schalke. Also ich wünsche mir jetzt auch einfach einen neuen Trainer, der endlich mal eine gesamtheitliche Idee auch mitbringt, beziehungsweise, ich will vielleicht noch einmal kurz ausholen, Schalke arbeitet seit einigen Monaten an so einem gesamtheitlichen Club-Statement oder Club-Philosophie. Da orientiert man sich sehr an Ajax Amsterdam. Also man will quasi für einen ganz klaren Fußball von der U15 bis zu den Profis stehen und dementsprechend dann auch im Laufe der kommenden Jahre mittelfristig Trainer und Spieler scouten und verpflichten. Und ich glaube, bis Sommer wird das Manifest stehen und danach sollte man dann auch einen Trainer suchen. Und der kann dann sehr, sehr glücklich sein, dass er einen Mike-Bio Buskins an seiner Seite hat.
Glaubst du denn, der Trainer steht schon fest? Ich hab nämlich letztens gelesen, als der Transfer von Leo Greibel zur neuen Saison bekanntgegeben wurde, dass schon Gerüchte gibt, dass ihm quasi schon der neue Trainer gesagt wurde und dass es jetzt quasi im Hintergrund erst mal geheim gehalten wird. Glaubst du, das stimmt? Oder sagt dein Gefühl, man wartet vielleicht doch noch bis zum Saisonende ab und schaut dann, ist dann wirklich der Ausstieg geschafft? Oder hat man es vielleicht am Ende dann doch nicht geschafft?
Ja, spannende Frage. Ich kann mir ehrlich gesagt beides vorstellen. Ich habe jetzt keine eigenen Infos, dass da Sachen schon fix wären. Ich schätze Schröder als jemanden ein, der auch vor der Demission von Gramozis seine Schattenliste hatte und vielleicht auch schon das eine oder andere Telefonat sehr nahe nach der Freistellung von Gramozis geführt hat. Ich finde es grundsätzlich einfach lustig, dass je näher Schalke der Bundesliga kommt, auch das Name-Dropping, das Schalke seit Jahren verfolgt hat, auch wieder größer und lauter und prominenter wird. Man hat das Gefühl, der Boulevard schmeißt jetzt wöchentlich zwei, drei neue Namen rein. Es hat ja angefangen mit Funkel über Fake, über Leitel, der zumindest irgendwie halbwegs bestätigt hat, dass es da zumindest irgendwie schon mal eine leichte Kontaktaufnahme gegeben hätte. Ich für meinen Teil denke mir auch noch zwei, drei Namen dazu und dann vertraue ich aber Schröder, dass der da schon die richtige Wahl trifft. Vielleicht hat er sie auch getroffen, aber ich glaube, er wird jetzt die Jungs und Büsskins erst mal die Saison zu Ende spielen lassen und die Fans feiern lassen dann hoffentlich den Aufstieg und dann werden wir schon früher oder später erfahren, wer den Greimel nächste Saison in der Bundesliga hoffentlich trainiert.
Wir warten es ab. Schalke 04 hat eigentlich ein hammerhartes Restprogramm. Das soll nicht untergehen. Von den letzten vier Gegnern kommen drei aus den Top 5 und der vierte ist SV Sandhausen, wo sich alle Top-Clubs bisher schwer getan haben auswärts. Es geht jetzt direkt weiter mit einem Heimspiel gegen Werder Bremen, dann Sandhausen, dann St. Pauli, dann der 1. FC Nürnberg. Aber durch diese 3 Punkte Vorsprung auf den Relegationsplatz könnte tatsächlich eben in verschiedenen Konstellationen das dann auch schnell geschafft sein mit dem Aufstieg. Ich hoffe, wir haben da jetzt nicht ein schlechtes Omen gebaut, in dem wir da schon so euphorisch drüber geredet haben. Aber es ist ja auch mal eine angenehme Note, wenn man über Schalke 04 spricht. Dann lasst uns aber auf den aktuell zweitplatzierten Blicken. Das ist Werder Bremen. Tobi, du hast vorhin schon ein bisschen gesprochen, also wir alle haben mitbekommen, der Wechsel von Markus Anfang zu Ole Werner war im Grunde der Beginn einer großen Liebesgeschichte und seitdem flog Werder auch relativ durch die Saison. Allerdings in den letzten drei Spielen jeweils nur ein Unentschieden geholt. Jetzt gerade auch am Wochenende ein 1 zu 1 zuhause gegen den 1. FC Nürnberg. Damit hat man zwar die Nürnberger distanzieren können, die hätten im Fall eines Sieges nochmal richtig eingreifen können in den Aufstiegs, ins Aufstiegsrennen. Wie schätzt du die Situation bei Werder ein?
Werder einzuschätzen fällt mir im Moment sogar recht schwer. Bis zu diesen drei Spielen, wo sie jetzt nicht gewonnen haben, drei Mal unentschieden gespielt haben, war ich eigentlich der Überzeugung, dass sie jetzt mit Ole Werner durchmarschieren. Der erste Hänger unter Werner muss man jetzt schauen. Das kommt natürlich zum sehr schlechten Zeitpunkt, gerade wo man jetzt auch noch die direkten Duelle, wie jetzt beispielsweise gegen Schalke, hat, die wirklich gerade mit sehr viel Selbstvertrauen ankommen. Grundsätzlich sage ich aber schon, dass bei Werner die Qualität vorhanden ist im Kader, dass man eigentlich den ersten oder zweiten Platz schaffen muss, meiner Meinung nach. Aber ob man jetzt direkt den Turnaround schafft, wird auf jeden Fall spannend zu sehen sein. Das muss man jetzt erstmal abwarten. Aber grundsätzlich, wenn man sich einfach nur die Qualität im Kader anguckt, sollte Werner das wohl irgendwie über die Bühne bringen und dann halt entweder vor oder hinter Schalke Platz 1 oder 2 machen.
Mensch, dafür, dass das so eng da oben ist, seid ihr ganz schön definitiv in euren Aussagen. Gehst du da mit, Dominik?
Ja, bei Bremen ist es ja ähnlich wie bei Schalke mit dem Kader, aber noch mal viel mehr Stammspieler aus der Bundesliga sind ja dem Club erhalten geblieben. Wo man auch erstmal, ich weiß, dass ich Anfang der Saison mich gefragt habe, ob ein Toprak sich jetzt komplett reinwirft oder ob er drauf pokert, ob er nicht noch in der September den Absprung schafft. Aber ich glaube, das ist das Pfauspfand, das Bremen durch die Saison mit sich trägt und jetzt auch noch mal in den Schlussspurt mitnehmen wird. Also einfach, dass man solche Unterschiedsspieler hat, wie Bittenkurt, wie zum Beispiel ein Toprak und vorne die beiden Stürmer Füchr und Duct, die ja auch so einfach super spielen. Dazu hat man mit Werner einen Trainer, den ich sehr schätze, dem man taktisch quasi jeden Gegner mit an die Hand geben kann. Der findet einen Plan, wie man ihm zumindest teilweise oder zeitweise das eigene Spiel aufdrücken kann. Aber Werner ist ja auch damals mit Kiel ein bisschen im Schlussspurt gestolpert. Das lag damals auch an Corona. Ich würde es ihm dementsprechend wünschen, wenn er jetzt mit weniger Stolperern durch den Schlussspurt kommt und dann auf einem direkten Aufstiegsplatz landet.
Letztendlich muss man sich das Schlussprogramm nochmal anschauen. Sie spielen jetzt auch Schalke und danach kommen eigentlich drei wirklich machbare Gegner mit Kiel, Aue und Regensburg. Zwei Heimspiele. Das kann auch nochmal am letzten Spieltag beispielsweise nochmal der Vorteil sein, dass Werder im Gegensatz zu anderen Teams oben ein Heimspiel hat, wo man nochmal vielleicht mit der letzten Kraft und der letzten Unterstützung der Fans nochmal vielleicht nochmal einen Rückstand drehen kann oder all solche Geschichten. Das hat man ja alles schon häufig genug gesehen. Ich würde da, wie gesagt, in dem Fall sagen, Qualität der Mannschaft und Qualität des Trainers gepaart mit dem Abschlussprogramm sollte am Ende reichen. Und wäre dann auch das versöhnliche Ende einer sehr wechselhaften Saison, wenn man es mal so sagen möchte.
Ich finde ein überaus versöhnliches Ende. Also nur aus der Distanz betrachtet und ohne es jemandem missgönnen zu wollen. Aber Werder hatte auch wirklich jetzt ein paar glückliche Ereignisse unter anderem, wie das 1 zu 1 bei St. Pauli zustande gekommen ist. Also es fällt gerade so viel in Richtung von Werder Bremen, dass es einen jetzt auch nicht wundern würde, wenn sie direkt aufsteigen könnten.
Das kommt ja noch dazu. Gut, da bin ich als Hamburger jetzt wahrscheinlich auch der vielleicht falsche Ansprechpartner. Aber ich habe auch so von anderen Freunden gehört, die halt sich auch quasi keinem Zweitligisten zugehörig führen auch gehört, sodass die mitbekommen haben, dass bei Werder schon einige glückliche Situationen gab. Auch der Elfmeter im Hinspiel gegen Schalke. Da holt man noch ganz glückliche 1-1, ein Spiel, das man eigentlich verloren hätte. Und letztendlich muss man ja auch sagen, mit Markus Anfang war man im Tabellmittefeld gewesen. Und da war schon quasi die Hinrunde vorbei. Ob man mit Anfang noch mal oben angegriffen hätte, ich bezweifle es eher. Und dann ist es ja auch, wenn es pr-mäßig eine Katastrophe war, was um Markus Anfang herum passiert ist. Aber für Werder aus sportlicher Sicht war es ja fast schon ein Glücksfall, dass man dann den Trainer wechseln konnte und auch noch den besten Trainer, der auf dem Markt war, mit Ole Werner verpflichten konnte.
Und der erst dann auf dem Markt war. Also da ging sich vielleicht los die Glückssträne von Werder Bremen. Ich glaube, so kann man das dann doch sagen. Ein bisschen anders sieht es aus, Dominik, beim FC St. Pauli. Die waren lange Zeit sehr souverän unterwegs an der Tabellenspitze. Jetzt musste man ein bisschen abreißen lassen aus den letzten 3 Spielen. Eine Niederlage und zwei Unentschieden, wenn auch zum Teil unglücklich. Gerade im Werder-Segment einmal kurz angesprochen. St. Pauli 53 Punkte, 3 Punkte Rückstand bzw. 1 Punkt Rückstand auf einen sicheren Aufstiegsplatz. Zwei Punkte Vorsprung auf Darmstadt A 98. Welchen Eindruck macht St. Pauli auf dich?
Grundsätzlich einen sehr guten. Ich finde, es ist eine Mannschaft, die absolut zu sich gefunden hat. Mit einem Trainer, der einen offensiven, klaren Plan verfolgt. Du hast es jetzt angesprochen, musst ein bisschen abreißen lassen. Sie haben unter anderem auch noch mal Schalke vor der Brust. Ich hätte zum Beispiel im Winter irgendwann gesagt, Pauli schafft es auf jeden Fall. Jetzt könnte es vielleicht sogar eher die Relegation oder der unglückliche vierte Platz kommen, wenn es ganz blöd für sie kommt. Aber es würde mich auch nicht wundern, wenn sie sich jetzt noch mal am Riemen reißen und noch mal den Turbo zünden können, weil die Mannschaft ist so eingespielt, dass sie spielerisch zumindest auf jeden Fall zu den besten drei Mannschaften gehören in der 2.
Liga.
Vielleicht ist das Pfund, obwohl man ein sehr schweres Restprogramm hat. St. Pauli spielt noch gegen Darmstadt auf 4, Nürnberg auf 5, Schalke auf 1 und dann kommt erst mit Fortuna Düsseldorf ein Team auf Rang 13. Das liest sich sehr schwer, es relativiert sich aber ein bisschen, Tobi, wenn man sich anschaut, drei dieser vier Spiele sind Heimspiele und St. Pauli ist die beste Heimannschaft der Liga. Vor dem 1. FC Heidenheim und dem HSV haben erst einmal zu Hause verloren. Ich denke, das wird so ein bisschen der Schlüssel für St. Pauli.
Ja, ich glaube auch, dass die Fans da nochmal den Verein pushen können. Das ist auch meiner Meinung nach vielleicht sogar das größte Faust fand, was St. Pauli hat im Gegensatz zu den Konkurrenten. Dass St. Pauli halt auch immer ein bisschen kleiner immer noch gesehen wird. Grundsätzlich muss da schon einiges passieren, um überhaupt eine negative Stimmung oder ein bisschen Angst mit rein zu bekommen in diesen Verein. Wenn man zum Beispiel jetzt beim HSV schaut, da wird ein Spiel in der Schlussphase verloren. Dann hat gleich die ganze Fan-Basis wieder Angst, dass man jetzt gar keinen Sieg mehr holt. St. Pauli ist es halt, wenn dort Rückschläge passieren, das stört den Verein quasi nicht länger. Man kann das eigentlich immer sehr gut abschütteln. Und am Millern-Tor sind sie eh stark. Bei Pauli ist einfach nicht dieser große Druck da, wie bei den anderen Teams. Deswegen könnte ich mir schon vorstellen, dass sie jetzt aus den letzten Spielen noch einiges rausholen. Aber ob das dann letztendlich reichen wird, da bin ich mir dann nicht ganz sicher, ob es dann die Punktzahl wirklich dann reichen wird. Aber ich glaube, dass St. Pauli die letzten Spiele auf jeden Fall, zumindest wie eigentlich die gesamte Saison, gute Leistung zeigen wird.
Also das Saisonfinale in der 2. Bundesliga. Es sieht wirklich sehr, sehr spannend aus. Die Frage ist dann, Dominik, wie wird der SV Darmstadt 98 da noch mitmischen können? Dieses 2 zu 5 jetzt zu Hause gegen Schalke 04, nachdem man sogar in Führung gegangen war in diesem Spiel, war das der vielleicht vorentscheidende Dämpfer, dass Darmstadt da jetzt nicht mehr rankommt? 2 Punkte sind es auf den Relikationsplatz, 3 Punkte auf den direkten Aufstieg?
Ja, man hat auf jeden Fall gesehen im Spiel gegen Schalke, dass die Nerven in Darmstadt etwas dünner werden. Also mich hat schon sehr überrascht, wie viel Thorsten Lieberknecht an der Seitenlinie lamentiert hat. Er hat wohl in einer Pressekonferenz ein paar Worte in Richtung Schiedsrichter von sich gegeben und versucht, sein Team stark zu reden und gesagt, man hätte eigentlich auf 2-0, 3-0 machen können. Dann kam es ganz anders und unglücklich. Man hat gesehen, er hat Angst, dass ihm die tolle Saisonleistung ein bisschen entgleitet. Ich glaube, unterm Strich würde niemand Thorsten Lieberknecht oder seinem Team in Darmstadt einen Strick drehen, wenn es nichts wird mit dem Aufstieg. Aber wenn man so lange oben dabei ist und auch teilweise so berauschenden Fußball gezeigt hat, wie Darmstadt, dann will man es sich eben auch nochmal selbst beweisen. Ich schaue gerade das Restprogramm. Es gibt ja auf jeden Fall doch nochmal irgendwie die Hoffnung, dass da noch was drin ist mit Aue und Paderborn, die auch immer gut sind für die Niederlage. Düsseldorf mit June natürlich nochmal sich total gefangen. Pauli als direkten Kandidaten, aber das sind dann auch so eine Floskel, aber das sind die Spiele, die man dann gewinnen muss. Von daher würde ich jetzt Darmstadt per se nicht komplett abschreiben, aber wir sind auf jeden Fall von den Mannschaften, die da noch mitmischen, wahrscheinlich die, die dann doch am meisten mit dem Rücken zur Wand stehen, auch weil sie eben nur noch gegen Pauli als direkten Kandidaten spielen müssen und quasi den möglichen Matchball oder zumindest das 40 zu 30 gegen Schalke, um in der Tennissprache zu bleiben, verpasst haben.
Sehr schön. Ich sehe schon alle Hörerinnen und Hörer vor mir, sich an Tennisregeln zurück erinnern. Tobi, gehst du bei dieser Einschätzung mit das Darmstadt? Man kann es ja auch anders herumdrehen. Klar, man spielt gegen nur noch einen direkten Konkurrenten mit St. Pauli, aber dafür ist das Restprogramm auf dem Papier leichter. Wenn die anderen sich gegenseitig die ganze Zeit unentschieden abluxen, das wäre jetzt die Darmstadt der Traumwelt, könnte ja der Theorie nach schon noch was gehen. Es ist ja nur die jüngste Entwicklung, die mit 4 Punkten aus 15 möglichen Punkten, also aus 5 Spielen, so schlecht ist.
Ja, ich finde Darmstadt auf jeden Fall sehr schwer einschätzbar. Was man schon sagen muss jetzt gerade in der Rückrunde, haben sie direkten Duellen gegen die Konkurrenz quasi, wenn ich das so sehe, alle verloren gegen uns 0-5. In Bremen gut gespielt, lange in Unterzahl, 1-0 verloren. Und jetzt die letzten beiden Spiele gegen Nürnberg und Schalke, halt 3-1 und 5-2. Da muss man dann gucken, ob sie jetzt im nächsten direkten Duell jetzt gegen St. Pauli da direkt rauskommen. Weil wenn sie jetzt da die dritte vielleicht sogar dann auch höhere oder deutlichere Niederlage kassieren, dann bin ich mir gar nicht so sicher, wie sie da zurückkommen. Und ich habe selber zwar auch hier mitphilosophiert, was ein schweres und was ein leichtes Restprogramm ist. Man kann es sich halt immer in jegliche Richtung drehen. Also wir haben ja auch schon in den letzten Jahren oft genug gesehen, dass wenn du am 33. Spieltag unbedingt einen Sieg brauchst gegen irgendeinen Abstiegskandidaten, der aber selber noch die Messer zwischen den Zehen hat und alles geben will oder geben muss, damit sie drinbleiben. Oder ein Team, das vielleicht einfach auf Platz 12 ist und sich denkt, okay, den versauen wir jetzt mal die Aufstiegsambition. Das kann genauso schwierig sein. Das ist vielleicht manchmal auch besser. Das hängt dann wahrscheinlich auch von Team zu Team unterschiedlich. Tun sich vielleicht andere auch einfach leichter mit dem sogenannten schweren Restprogramm und die anderen tun sich leichter mit dem leichten Restprogramm. Also bei Darmstadt, um noch mal darauf zurückzukommen, das finde ich ganz schwer einzuschätzen. Vom Gefühl her würde ich eher sagen, dass es am Ende nicht reichen wird.
Und was sagt dein Gefühl beim 1. FC Nürnberg? Der hat jetzt eben 1 zu 1 bei Werder gespielt. Zur 1 zu 0-Führung sah es lange sehr, sehr gut aus für den Club. Da sah es auch so aus, als könne man da noch mal so richtig ran springen an die Aufstiegsringe. Jetzt sind es 3 Punkte auf die Relegation, 4 Punkte auf den direkten Aufstieg. Man spielt jetzt dann gegen Sandhausen und wird auch noch gegen St. Pauli und den FC Schalke 04 spielen müssen. Hat sich der Club schon verabschiedet aus dem Aufstiegsrennen? Die Verantwortlichen müssen natürlich Nein sagen. Wie siehst du es?
Nee, verabschiedet haben sie sich nicht. Aber ja, sind für mich auch kein Favorit jetzt auf den Aufstieg. Wird auch interessant sein, wie die Konstellation vom 34. Spieltag sein wird. Auch gerade mit dem guten Verhältnis zwischen Schalke und Nürnberg. Ob der eine dem anderen vielleicht sogar ein Bein stellen kann, beziehungsweise sogar muss vielleicht, je nachdem. Oder beiden reicht ein Punkt, weiß man ja auch nicht. Also Nürnberg sehe ich auf jeden Fall noch im Rennen, aber haben halt wirklich nicht die besten Chancen. Und bei Nürnberg bin ich mir auch nicht ganz sicher, da sie auch eine recht junge Mannschaft haben. Ob sie schon quasi bereit dafür sind aufzusteigen oder ob es auch gerade für Nürnberg, auch mit einem jungen Trainer noch, ob es nicht noch mal besser wäre, noch einmal eine Runde in der zweiten Liga zu drehen, um dann noch mal gefestigter im nächsten Jahr anzugreifen.
Max, ich muss auch sagen, du hast jetzt gesagt, als Nürnberg überhaupt jetzt schon raus aus dem Aufstiegskandidat, ich muss eher sagen, ich bin überrascht, dass Nürnberg dabei ist. Also, es ist jetzt gar nicht despektierlich gemeint gegenüber Nürnberg, sondern ich hatte zum Beispiel eher das Gefühl, dass Heidenheim beispielsweise, die jetzt auf jeden Fall raus sind, sehr lange noch oben irgendwie dabei waren. Selbst Regensburg war ja, gefühlt die ganze Hinrunde, waren die ein Top-Ausstiegskandidat. Und irgendwie hat Nürnberg sich sehr kontinuierlich rangeroppt. Aber auch, muss ich sagen, ich frage mich, wie sie das gemacht haben, weil also die Offensive...
Ohne Stürme auf jeden Fall.
Genau, genau, das ist es, wo wir irgendwie bei Schalke und selbst beim HSV sagen können, die haben mit Tirodde und Glazel auf jeden Fall zwei Torgaranten. Auch dahinter immer irgendwie jemanden, der sie füttert, sagen wir mal Kittel und Bülter oder auch Ojan, weiß ich irgendwie bei Nürnberg nicht so richtig, einen Spieler rauszugreifen. Aber vielleicht ist es genau das, was Nürnberg ausmacht, dass jeder so für den anderen einsteht und jeder irgendwie auch mal den Torabschluss nimmt und dann mal trifft, also sehr homogen als Mannschaft einfach auftritt. Und was Tobi gesagt hat, muss man mal schauen, wie die Konstellation ist vom letzten Spieltag bei Schalke-Nürnberg, bzw. Nürnberg-Schalke, ja, auf jeden Fall kann ich verstehen diesen Gedanken als auswärtigen Fan. Ich kann da aber nur dran erinnern, mir ist das ja leider ein Fallen, aber Bundesliga, letzter Spieltag auch, Nürnberg gegen Schalke, Max Morlock-Stadion, wo es für Nürnberg um den Klassenerhalt ging und Schalke, ich glaube, um die Champions-League-Quali. Und Schalke dann Javier Pinoaula ins Tal der Tränen geschossen hat, ich glaube, in seinem letzten Spiel für Nürnberg. Also ich glaube nicht, dass Schalke irgendwie Rücksicht nehmen würde, also 1-1 reicht uns, so Schande von Cordoba-mäßig oder Ähnliches. Also ich glaube, da wären beide Mannschaften ganz normal mit dem Wunsch, drei Punkte zu holen, ins Spiel zu gehen, egal ob jetzt irgendwie zweiter gegen dritter oder erster gegen vierter oder wie auch immer da die Konstellation sein sollte.
Gut, das werden wir ja dann auch beobachten können. Für mich eine ganz spannende Frage ist, Tobi, werden wir denn auch den HSV noch einmal zurück begrüßen können im Aufstiegsrennen? Es sind schon fünf Punkte Rückstand auf den Relegationsplatz, damit logischerweise sechs Punkte auf den ersten direkten Aufstiegsplatz. Eigentlich würde man sagen, alles wie immer, der HSV hat es im April nicht hinbekommen. Ich finde, es gibt aber Faktoren, die dagegen sprechen. Zum einen, dass ebenso viele direkte Konkurrenten noch gegeneinander spielen. Das heißt, es werden nicht alle Mannschaften durchmarschieren können. Und dann vielleicht durchaus das Spiel am Wochenende, wo man sehr deutlich mit 3 zu 0 gegen den KSC gewonnen hat. Wie schätzt du die Situation beim HSV ein?
Ja, auch das ist nochmal ganz schwierig. Ich werde ja auch als HSVer quasi seit Monaten oder seit Saisonbeginn nach jedem Spiel gefragt. Steigt ihr auf? Steigt ihr nicht auf? Und ich bin eigentlich eher negativ gestimmt, was das angeht, schon die gesamte Saison über. Und jetzt würde ich sogar eigentlich sagen, dass man fast aus dem Rennen raus ist. Auch wenn natürlich, das merkt man ja auch, jetzt jeder den HSV da irgendwie als Sechsten noch auf jede Liste da noch irgendwie mit rein nimmt, wenn es darum geht, wer könnte noch aufsteigen. Aber du hast ja auch schon gesagt, da spielen zwar noch viele gegeneinander, aber aus HSV-Sicht muss man ja fast schon hoffen, dass die fast alle unentschieden spielen. Und die Chance ist schon recht gering. Und wenn man mal sieht, man kann nur 60 Punkte im Maximalfall erreichen, das sind dann für Werder und Schalke alleine, sind das glaube ich jetzt zwei Siege aus vier Spielen, die denen dann schon reichen würden. Und dann wird es halt nur noch um Rang 3 gehen. Und dass dann quasi St. Pauli, Darmstadt und Nürnberg jetzt quasi einbrechen, halte ich fast schon für unmöglich. Und zu dem Spiel jetzt hier gegen den KSC am Wochenende, ja, das war gut. Hätte man so in den Wochen davor gespielt, hätte man sicher noch den einen oder anderen Punkt geholt. Auf der anderen Seite hat es auch wieder das HSV-Problem gezeigt. Die Woche davor in Kiel, da hätte man unbedingt gewinnen müssen und hat es wiederum nicht geschafft. Jetzt, wo man dann gegen den KSC oder vor dem Spiel schon quasi sagen musste, das Ding ist durch, kann man sich noch mal aufraffen. Und das zeigt halt das Problem auch der letzten Jahre, dass man so ab Spieltag 28 bis Gefühl 33 alles verloren hat, den Ausstieg vergeigt hat. Und dann am letzten Spieltag gibt es noch mal ein schönes 4-0 gegen Braunschweig oder vergleichbaren Gegner, der dann halt einfach nichts mehr bringt, weil es zu spät ist. Also ich persönlich glaube nicht mehr daran, auch wenn da natürlich sehr viel Selbstschutz auch dabei ist, dass man sich einredet, dass es nicht mehr klappt. Die Hoffnung in Hamburg ist auf jeden Fall noch da, aber ich persönlich glaube nicht daran.
Und wenn es jetzt nicht geklappt haben sollte, woran wird es gelegen haben in der Rückschau? Was sind die Knackpunkte der Saison? Sind es wirklich wieder in Anführungszeichen nur weiche Faktoren, wie eben, dass man dann, wenn der Druck dann so groß wird, weil man etwas, also sobald man etwas zu verlieren hat, dann schlottern dem HSV die Knie oder sobald der Frühling anbricht, wird es schwierig. Ist es so einfach?
Ich glaube mittlerweile, dass es wirklich so einfach ist, weil wir hatten auch jetzt wieder die Phase, kurz nach Beginn der Rückrunde, wo man gegen St. Pauli gewonnen hat, direkt danach 5-0 in Darmstadt gewonnen hat, wo natürlich hier auch wieder die Euphorie riesig war. Man sich dachte, okay, dieses Mal packen wir es auch, gerade weil gefühlt der HSV diese Saison insgesamt auch sehr viel schöner in Fußball gespielt hat. Und man auch wirklich mal wieder richtig Spaß hatte, dauerhaft ins Stadion zu gehen, wenn man dann durfte. Aber zumindest das HSV-Spiele sich anzugucken. Und dann hat man trotzdem gemerkt, bzw. in Hamburg merkt man dann schon, dass bei vielen eingefleischten Fans, es geht dann ab Spieltag 23, 24, 25, eigentlich gibt es nur noch zwei Lager. Das eine Lager sagt, wir werden eh noch einbrechen. Und das zweite Lager redet sich ein, dass man nicht einbrechen wird. Aber dieses Thema ist einfach dauerhaft anwesend. Und es ist eigentlich schon in der Hinrunde anwesend, weil man dann schon sagt, okay, man muss gefühlt jetzt schon jeden Punkt mitnehmen, weil man am Ende wieder die Punkte liegen lässt. Und dann war es dann so vor vier, fünf Wochen, sag ich mal, oder ab dem Werder-Spiel, was man ja dann knapp verloren hat, auch durch zwei VAR-Entscheidungen und ein Abseitstor, was wieder in der letzten Sekunde nicht gegeben wurde zum Ausgleich, da musste man schon wieder das Gefühl bekommen, okay, bald das Zittern geht wieder los. Und ja, man bekommt das hier auch irgendwie nicht weg. Also man merkt ja auch, wir haben ja jetzt auch genug Spieler ausgetauscht jedes Jahr. Und es ist jetzt trotzdem wieder so, dass man nach Kiel fährt und einfach da keinen Punkt holt bzw. keinen Sieg holt. Dass man nach Düsseldorf fährt und man merkt richtig, dass die Spieler einfach, dass sie nicht frei sind. Dass sie halt einfach nicht das Spiel, was sie davor in vielen Teilen der Saison gespielt haben, einfach nicht auf den Rasen kriegen. Und dann hat man teilweise, das bestätigen wir auch viele andere HSV-Fans, aber auch welche, die andere Vereine unterstützen, dass man da teilweise schon das Gefühl hat, dass man einfach sieht, dass da die Spieler gehemmt sind. Und das, finde ich, persönlich zieht sich bisher durch jede Saison quasi. Und wir hatten es ja auch schon vorher auch unter Hannes Wolf in der ersten Zweitligasaison. Da gewinnst du am 25. oder 26. Spieltag 4-0 auf St. Pauli und denkst dir, okay, jetzt musst du eigentlich diesen Sprung mitnehmen und durchmarschieren. Ja, danach verlierst du die Woche danach 3-2 zuhause gegen Darmstadt, nachdem du sicher 2-0 geführt hast, das ganze Stadion bebt. Ja, und dann zieht sich das wieder durch. Das Jahr danach 6-2 gegen den VfB. Was war hier für eine Euphorie? Dieses Jahr ziehen wir durch. Ja, bis dann wieder das berühmte Programm kam in den letzten Spieltagen. Also ich persönlich habe mittlerweile keine andere Erklärung mehr dafür, als dass es ein psychologisches Problem ist in diesem Verein. Und was sich dann auch in der Mannschaft quasi dann abspielt ab einem gewissen Zeitpunkt.
Aber wenn wir jetzt nochmal die Saison quasi einzeln betrachten, würdest du vielleicht auch sagen, dass der HSV ein Stück weit jetzt in Schönheit davonsicht oder so in Schönheit stirbt. Das ist so ein Aspekt, den ich von vielen Schalke-Fans irgendwie mitbekommen habe oder gehört habe. Dass sie sagen, von der reinen Auslegung des Spiels, von der Spielidee von Tim Walter her, ist Hamburg das Zweitligateam, was sie, abgesehen von Schalke, am liebsten schauen. Aber es fehlt dem HSV an der einen oder anderen Stelle am schlichten Pragmatismus, den es zum Beispiel auf Schalke in vielen Gamotzespielen gab. Wäre das so eine These, die du unterschreiben würdest, oder wo du Aspekte siehst, die dagegen sprechen, das würde mich noch mal interessieren.
Da würde ich auf jeden Fall zustimmen. Ich habe ja auch vorhin bei Schalke gesagt, dass über weite Teile der Gamotzes-Ära, jetzt hier in der 2. Liga, das Spielprinzip war, einer flankt aus dem Halbfeld und vorne steht der Rodde und haut den Ball irgendwie über die Linie. Der HSV hatte da quasi exakt den gegenteiligen Ansatz. Wir haben so mutig wie noch nie hinten rausgespielt. Da gab es sehr viele Fans, denen das schon zu mutig war. So dass heuer Fernandez auch schon weit vor der Kiste steht. Man spielt hinten ruhig den Ball raus, aber auch mit einem gewissen Risiko. Wir hatten ja auch viele Unentschieden gehabt, gerade in der Hinrunde. Den Schuh muss man sich definitiv anziehen, wo man sich auch auf den Unentschieden ein bisschen ausgeruht hat. Da gab es viele Spiele, wo man die klar bessere Mannschaft war, gerade in Heimspielen, und geht dann mit einem Torschussverhältnis von 18 zu 4 raus und spielt 2-2 gegen Darmstadt quasi. Bei Schalke sehe ich mehr Effizienz, dass man aus den Chancen, die man auch hat, mehr Tore schießt und auch mal die dreckigen Siege holt. Beim HSV stand man ab einem gewissen Zeitpunkt, wo es unentschieden stand, weiter auf das schöne Spiel beharrt hat, statt noch mal zu sagen, die letzte Viertelstunde drängen wir auf das 2 zu 1. Man hat ja auch beim HSV lange gesagt, ich glaube, bis zum Werder-Spiel hatten wir zwei Spiele nur verloren. Da hieß es ja auch immer, der HSV hat die wenigsten Niederlagen der Liga. Aber sie haben auch mit Abstand die meisten Unentschieden gehabt. In der Masse fällt es auf, wenn du 13-mal Unentschieden spielst, aber dementsprechend wenig Siege holst. Andere holen mit deutlich weniger Mitteln viel mehr Siege. Es ist ja leider die Rechnung, dass ein Sieg so viele Punkte macht, wie drei Unentschieden. Also hat man sich teilweise, glaube ich auch so, wie dann die Schalker auch sagen, ein bisschen verloren in diesem schönen Spiel, sei ich mal, den Wunsch, schön zu spielen, attraktiv zu spielen. Und hätte vielleicht mit bisschen mehr Pragmatismus einige Punkte mehr holen müssen.
Was mich noch interessiert, ich möchte jetzt gar nicht Max seinen Job streitig machen, die Fragen zu stellen. Du hast ja vorhin auch angesprochen, dass natürlich auch viele Spieler jetzt wieder neu dazukommen sind, viele gegangen sind, was wahrscheinlich auch eben daran liegt, dass viele Spieler zum HSV gehen, mit dem Ziel aufzusteigen. Und dann ziehen sie weiter, wenn es nicht klappt. Aber ich kann da zum Beispiel nur zwei Namen rausnehmen. Also den Sebastian Schoenler und den Louis-Louis Reis. Den hatte Schalke auch auf Erliste. Die beiden hätte ich auch sehr gerne im königsblauen Trikot gesehen. Dazu Mario Vusković. Da war ich sehr überrascht, als Heiduk Split-Sympathisant, dass der beim HSV gelandet ist. Der macht sich ja auch sehr gut in dieser Saison. Glaubst du aber, würdest du trotz dieser auf dem Papier guten Transfers auch die Transfer- oder die Personalpolitik von Jonas Boldt und Co. in Frage stellen oder kritisieren? Oder glaubst du, es fehlt eine Achse, die sich über die letzten Zweitliga-Jahre eingespielt hat?
Die Transfers in dieser Saison fand ich außer den Transfer von Mikkel Kaufmann, der aber auch, muss man fairerweise sagen, kam zu einem Zeitpunkt, wo man davon ausging, dass man mit 2 Stürmern spielen wird, wovon man ja relativ schnell weggekommen ist und im 4-3-3 meistens spielt. Abgesehen von dem Einkauf war die Transferpolitik eigentlich gut gewesen. Schonlau und Vusković hast du ja angesprochen, die machen sich eigentlich sehr gut in der Innenverteidigung. Stehen auch für einen spielerischen Spielaufbau und nicht nur für lange Hafer nach vorne. Ganz wichtig zum Beispiel auch Jonas Meffert, der eigentlich fast schon der wichtigste Spieler beim HSV geworden ist. Wo ich wirklich sagen muss, ein Punkt, den man kritisieren muss, war auf jeden Fall in der Winterpause, wo man jetzt eigentlich Flügelspieler gebraucht hätte, weil man dann gemerkt hat, als klassischen Flügelspieler hat man eigentlich nur Jatta. Hat dann aber trotzdem durchgehend mit zwei Flügeln gespielt. Dann kam ja Farid Ali Duh quasi aus dem Nichts mit einem sehr großen Hype aus der zweiten Mannschaft hoch. Da hätte man in der Winterpause eigentlich noch mal sagen müssen, okay, jetzt wollen wir auch noch mal wirklich oben angreifen. Wir brauchen gerade in der Kaderbreite noch zwei, drei Spieler. Dann kam letztendlich noch kurz vor Transfer-Schuss Chuck Wetaze. Eigentlich ein sehr guter Spieler, der auch in Belgien schon vor knapp zwei Jahren schon eines der größten Talente der Liga war. Da weiß ich noch, dass unser Belgien-Experte bei Transfermarkt, wie er mir jede Woche von Chuck Wetaze vorgeschwärmt hat, wo man auch merkt, der ist eigentlich schon vielleicht sogar fast zu gut für die 2. Liga, aber der passt halt auch nicht wirklich ins System, weil dieser klassische Flügelspieler, den er dann geben soll, wenn er spielt, ist er halt auch wieder nicht. Also hat man meiner Meinung nach wirklich im Winter nicht genügend nachgelegt. Bei Bolld an sich, bei der Kaderplanung, muss man auch nochmal sagen, dass im letzten Jahr halt sehr viel oder in der letzten Saison halt sehr viel daneben gegangen ist, wo man gesagt hat, okay, wir setzen jetzt auf diese sogenannten Säulenspieler und die haben ja von Cezula bis Ulreich. Und ich würde sogar persönlich sagen, fast schon Terode am Ende halt einfach nicht funktioniert. Terode hat zwar auch seine Tore gemacht bei uns, aber letztendlich in der kritischen Phase, wo man ihn ja eigentlich wie auf Schalke jetzt als Führungsspieler geholt hat, wo er jetzt auch auf Schalke zeigt, dass er treffen kann, hat er in der Schlussphase der Saison beim HSV halt auch nicht mehr getroffen. Also ist das auch nochmal ein Punkt für mich, was diesen, ja, was ich eben schon meinte, diese psychische Prophezeiung, dass man am Ende es nicht schaffen wird, eigentlich nochmal bestätigt, dass selbst der Rodde in dem Zeitpunkt, wo der HSV jedes Mal abschmiert, auch nicht treffen konnte. Und auf Schalke zeigt er halt jetzt wieder das Gegenteil.
Ich würde an der Stelle ganz gerne einhaken, weil ihr habt jetzt ganz gut den Kader skizziert und so auch ein bisschen den Saisonverlauf. Ich erinnere mich, dass wir hier im Herbst irgendwann über den HSV gesprochen haben. Und da haben wir darüber gesprochen, dass angeblich der Stuhl von Walther schon gewackelt habe, aber Jonas Beuth dann ausgegeben hat, Saisonziel ist die Entwicklung. Es geht nicht mehr um den Ausstieg an sich, sondern um eine Wertentwicklung. Denn der HSV könne nicht mehr fertige Spieler kaufen. Und als wir da jetzt vorhin darüber gesprochen haben über dieses immer wiederkehrende Phänomen des Einbrechens im Frühjahr, da habe ich mich zurückerinnert, wie das auch die einzelnen Trainer erlebt haben. Denn das gehört ja zum HSV dazu, dass es eben schon sehr viele unterschiedliche Trainer gab. Also Tune im letzten Jahr, Dieter Hecking davor, Hannes Wolf hast du vorhin auch schon genannt. Und wenn ich mich richtig erinnere, dann war das bei allen Trainern so, dass sie zu Beginn der Rückrunde und dann auch, wenn die ersten Rückschläge kamen, im Februar, März gesagt haben, ja, das kriegen wir schon hin, das wird alles easy, wir müssen jetzt ruhig bleiben. Und dann am Ende waren sie doch davon überrascht, welche Wucht diese Dynamik aufgenommen hat, dass man eben dann doch es einfach gesagt vergeigt mit dem Aufstieg, ohne dass ich das jetzt... Ja, das hört sich zu salopp an, also ich mein's jetzt nicht abwertend, aber es hat eben einfach nicht geklappt. Meinst du, das wäre eine entscheidende Stellschraube, dass man vielleicht einem Trainer mal eine zweite Saison gibt, dass er auch diese Dynamik schon kennt? Glaubst du, Tim Walter könnte dieser Trainer sein?
Also ich bin der Meinung, dass man an Tim Walter festhalten sollte. Auch da erlebe ich gemischte oder höre ich gemischte Stimmen. Auch aus meinem bekannten Kreis und auch, ja, was HSV-Fans allgemein angeht. Man muss ja auch mittlerweile sagen, wir haben jetzt so oft den Trainer gewechselt. Alles, was wir oder das Einzige, was wir noch nicht versucht haben, ist, mal mit dem Trainer in die zweite Saison zu gehen. Deswegen kann man ja schon sagen, okay, neuer Trainer wäre genauso mutig. Warum gehen wir jetzt nicht mal den mutigen Schritt und behalten ihn einfach mal? Und ich würde es halt aber auch bei Tim Walther davon abhängig machen, dass man auch weiter schaut und an dem Konzept, was man jetzt eigentlich die Saison gemacht hat, auch so mit Spieler aus der eigenen Jugend heranzuführen bzw. allgemein auf eine junge Mannschaft zu setzen. Weil auch der HSV hatte ja teilweise ganz junge Spieler auf dem Platz gehabt. Also ich kann jetzt leider nicht nachgucken, aber der HSV hat keinen Spieler, der 30 Jahre ist oder älter. Ich glaube, Heuer Fernandes und Kittel sind mit 29 die ältesten Spieler im Kader. Und dass man einfach diesen Weg quasi beibehält, wobei man da natürlich auch sagen muss, dass wenn man jetzt an ihm festhält, dann muss da auch ein gewisser Erfolg schon zu Saisonbeginn zu sehen sein. Also man könnte sich das dann nicht leisten, quasi jetzt zu sagen, okay, wir bleiben oder behalten Walter und schauen dann mal, ob das dann irgendwann in der nächsten Saison besser wird.
Aber glaubt ihr denn, er würde passen von der Art des Spielens und auch von der Art, wie er mit dem Umfeld umgeht?
Ich finde schon. Also er gibt auch vielen Fans das Gefühl, dass er auch gerne hier ist. Natürlich muss man natürlich auch mal sehen, die Leute wollen sich auch immer von ihrer besten Seite zeigen. Und es lief ja auch lange genug gut bei uns. Da gab es ja auch quasi keinen Grund, ja, nicht seine beste Seite zu zeigen oder halt an seiner positiven Ausstrahlung zu zweifeln. Aber der Spielstil, den wir haben, grundsätzlich gefällt glaube ich vielen. Ich habe von vielen gehört dieses Jahr, die meinen, es macht viel mehr Spaß, dieses Jahr HSV-Spiele zu sehen als in den Saisons davor. Auch gerade mit diesem mutigen Spielaufbau. Und ja, man spielt sich ja wirklich viele Chancen heraus in den meisten Spielen. Und ja, der Weg auch mit den jungen Spielern, der gefällt eigentlich schon vielen. Es ist halt immer nur die Frage, wie getrieben ist der Verein oder auch die einzelnen Fans immer von dem Aufstieg. Es gibt ja auch genug Leute, die sagen, man könnte, oder man sollte jetzt erst mal dieses Jahr gar nicht aufsteigen und sich weiter festigen und dann im nächsten Jahr aufsteigen. Also diese Meinung gibt es auch unter HSV-Fans. Ich habe aber auch das Gefühl, dass es halt auch von den Medien und dem Umfeld auch gar nicht akzeptiert wird. Also ich kenne das wie gesagt selber auch. Wenn ich zum Beispiel gefragt werde jeden Tag, ja, oder nach jedem Spiel steigt der HSV auf und ich sage nein, ich glaube nicht, dann sind alle direkt geschockt. So nach dem Motto, wie kannst du nur sagen, dass der Verein nicht aufsteigt? Und manchmal habe ich das Gefühl, dass von außen die Leute einem auch viel mehr oder auch dem HSV viel mehr dieses, ihr müsst aufsteigen, aufzwingen wollen, als man es vielleicht auch selber teilweise sagt. Also es ist ganz schwierig, wie ich auch gesagt habe, bei St. Pauli gibt es gefühlt wenig Druck. Das ist beim HSV halt ganz anders. Es ist ja auch bei Schalke so, wenn jetzt Werder dreimal in Folge 1.1 gespielt, das kriegen viele gar nicht so mit. Auf Schalke würde jetzt wieder oder jetzt hier beim HSV, würde das Thema, würde das in den Medien wieder ganz anders aufgefasst werden. Da würde wieder geredet werden von, schaffen sie es dieses Jahr wieder nicht, haben sie wieder Angst. Ich finde, Walter wäre auf jeden Fall jetzt mal ein Trainer, an dem man festhalten kann, dem man eine zweite Chance geben sollte. Auch im Pokal läuft das ja sehr, sehr gut dieses Jahr. Das wäre vielleicht mal der Schritt, der vielleicht wirklich der mutigste beim HSV wäre, wenn man sagt, wir ändern den Weg jetzt nicht, sondern wir versuchen es jetzt im zweiten Anlauf unter ihm.
Damit hast du ja schon die Brücke gebaut zum letzten Thema, das wir unbedingt noch ansprechen müssen. Wir nehmen jetzt am Oster Montag auf. Das heißt, morgen Abend, am Dienstagabend, wirst du irgendwann wissen, ob der HSV es geschafft hat, ins DFB-Pokalfinale einzuziehen. Man ist in diesem Wettbewerb nach einem 2 zu 1 in Braunschweig in jeder Runde über Elfmeterschießen weitergekommen. Also würde es einen jetzt auch nicht komplett aus den Socken hauen, wenn es jetzt wieder bis ins Elfmeterschießen ging. Man hat bisher gegen Braunschweig, Nürnberg, Köln und Karlsruhe jeweils gewonnen. Jetzt kommt der SC Freiburg. Ich glaube, was emotional dieses Spiel bedeutet, das ist allen klar. Der letzte Titel des HSV liegt schon so weit zurück, dass ich es gerade nicht im Kopf ausrechnen kann. 25 Jahre, nein, 35 Jahre, 1987 war das der DFB-Pokal. Welche Bedeutung hat denn dieses Spiel aus finanzieller Sicht? Weiß man darüber auch was?
Ja, aus finanzieller Sicht ist das Spiel sehr, sehr, sehr wichtig. Wir haben ja auch gesehen, nachdem wir quasi in die Zeitfinale eingezogen sind, dass man direkt danach auch den Transfer von Vuzković quasi fixiert hat. Der war ja vorher auch ausgeliehen mit einer Kaufoption beziehungsweise Kaufpflicht dann bei Aufstieg, wo man jetzt aber dem Vernehmen nach sich bei einer niedrigeren Ablöse geeinigt hat, weil auch Split das Geld lieber vorher haben wollte als später. Und Muhaym, der Ersatz von Leibold ist, der ja schon quasi die Hälfte der Saison ausfällt, den haben wir auch verpflichtet, kurz nachdem wir den Halbfinaleinzug geschafft haben. Also da merkt man richtig, dass allein schon das Preisgeld uns sehr, sehr gut tut und auch für die weitere Planung sehr wichtig ist. Aber grundsätzlich, glaube ich, hat hier jeder, wenn nicht gerade Jonas Boldt ist, nicht den finanziellen Aspekt vor Augen, sondern einfach diesen Traum, dass man einmal nach Berlin fahren darf mit seinem Verein. Seit Wochen oder quasi seit der Auslosung sind, soweit ich weiß, alle HSV-Fans heiß auf dieses Spiel morgen. Und viele haben auch große Hoffnungen und sind zuversichtlich.
Warum auch nicht ist alles möglich in einem Spiel. Man hat es bisher in allen anderen Partien auch hinbekommen. Egal wie es gelaufen ist, Doppelkontakt. Florian Kainz im Elfmeterschießen vom 1. Auch wenn du mich jetzt indirekt als Jonas Beuth bezeichnet hast, weil ich nach den Finanzen gefragt habe. Aber sag gerne noch ein paar Worte dazu. Der HSV, er hat ja eine große Tradition. Und die ist ja auch nicht erfolglos. Auch wenn ich jetzt den letzten Titel zitiert habe, der lange zurückliegt, aber man war ja auch Teilnehmer im UEFA Cup und sogar in der Europa League 2009, 2010 war man noch mit dabei. Das ist ja wiederum erst 13 Jahre her. Glaubst du, das könnte ja auch so eine Initialzündung sein, mal wieder einen Erfolg mit diesem Verein erlebt zu haben, dass vielleicht auch man nicht immer nur an die verpassten Aufstiege denkt, wenn man jetzt an die letzten Jahre zurückdenkt?
Ja, ob es eine Initialzündung ist oder sein kann, das wäre mir zu schwer, das quasi so einordnen zu können. Aber der Einzug ins Finale, das wäre auch für viele hier in Hamburg bzw. die auch dem HSV die Daumen drücken, auch einfach so eine Art Genugtuung. Wie ich ja schon gesagt habe, man hat immer ein bisschen die Versagensangst am Ende seit Jahren. Und das wäre jetzt mal so ein wichtiges Spiel, wo man sagen kann, wenn wir das gegen den SC Freiburg gewinnen und auch noch ins Finale einziehen, gegen wen dann auch immer dieses Spiel dann stattfinden würde. Das wäre halt einfach, dass man diese letzte Hürde, an der man quasi die letzten Jahre auch im Aufstiegskampf immer gescheitert ist, hätte man die schon mal überwunden. Und dann das Finale wäre dann halt nur noch quasi die Zugabe. Da muss man ja fast schon ausgehen, gegen Leipzig spielen zu müssen. Da kann man sich die Chancen dann auch nochmal ausrechnen. Aber ja, ich glaube, es würde mir zu weit gehen, zu sagen, es wäre eine Initialzündung für die nächsten Jahre. Aber es wäre auf jeden Fall für die Fernsehle sehr erfrischend und finanziell natürlich auch.
Ja, das muss man ja eigentlich jedem Fan eines solchen Vereins wie des HSVs sehr wünschen, weil man da eben nicht nur sportliche Misere erlebt hat, sondern das Ganze eben auch unter dem Brennglas der Öffentlichkeit. Das ist einfach der Unterschied zu vielen anderen Vereinen, ich glaube sogar zu solchen wie dem 1. FC Kaiserslautern, wobei es sein kann, dass ich da jetzt dann auch verdränge, weil ich das nicht mehr so mitbekomme, weil die jetzt bis in die 3. Liga runtergereicht wurden. Aber die letzten Jahre als HSV-Fan, die waren nicht einfach. Ich habe das immer indirekt gespürt, wenn sich Menschen bei mir beschwert haben, weil sie mir unterstellt haben, ich würde den HSV nicht mögen, ich mag nur die Formmusik nicht, ansonsten habe ich überhaupt keine Probleme mit diesem Verein. Die ist wirklich ganz, ganz hervorragend. Das ist das Einzige, wo ich dem HSV etwas missgönne, wenn sie einen Tor geschossen haben, denke ich mir, muss ich jetzt wieder diesen Mist hören. Aber wir werden es sehen. Ich wünsche dir auf jeden Fall, dass du es irgendwie genießen kannst, dieses Spiel. Auch wenn ich weiß, dass man da immer so angespannt ist, dass das sehr schwierig ist. Damit beschließen wir den Aufstiegspart. Eigentlich wollten wir noch über den FC Heidenheim sprechen, aber die haben sich selber rausgenommen aus diesem Segment. Und diese Sendung wird sowieso schon lang genug haben. 0 zu 2 verloren zu Hause gegen Aue. Damit ist Heidenheim raus. Die haben jetzt 8 Punkte Rückstand auf den Relegationsplatz. Das wird nichts mehr werden. Deshalb lasst noch schnell in ein paar Worten über den Abstiegskampf sprechen. Da hat einer von euch beiden, ich weiß gerade gar nicht mehr, ob es du warst, Dominik, gesagt, dass Düsseldorf ja jetzt auch mit Etion sich stabilisiert hat, da rausgekommen ist. Zwar gab es nur in Anführungszeichen ein Unentschieden bei Hannover 96 in Überzahl. An diesem Samstag aber, man kann in der Tat sagen, bei acht Punkten Vorsprung auf den Relikationsplatz scheint es so zu sein, als hätte sich die Fortuna gerettet.
Ja, also ich meine, Tune hat, also ich glaube, auch einfach die ganze Mannschaft stabilisiert. Nicht nur was punktemäßig jetzt, also die Punkte angeht und den Tabellenplatz, aber hat einfach auch nochmal irgendwie die Spieler neu erreicht und eine Aufbruchsstimmung geschaffen. Ich meine, Tune war ja sowohl in Osnabrück als auch in Hamburg, auch wenn Tobi das wahrscheinlich nicht so gerne hören möchte, durchaus erfolgreicher Trainer. Dass es jetzt in Hamburg nicht mit dem Aufstieg geklappt hat, ist natürlich ärgerlich oder schade, je nachdem. Aber auch wenn man sich jetzt anschaut, Düsseldorf ist ja von den ganzen Teams, die unten drin sind, die einzige Mannschaft, die ein positives Torverhältnis hat. Das spricht ja eigentlich auch für die Stabilität dieser ganzen Mannschaft. Und von daher kann man, glaube ich, schon mal Glückwünsche an Daniel Thun und die Fortuna-Senden für den Klassenerhalt.
Tobi, wie blickst du auf den Erfolg von Thun bei Düsseldorf? Würdest du dir da manchmal wünschen, dass man da vielleicht sich nicht getrennt hätte voneinander?
Ja, den Wunsch hatte ich natürlich, weil das ausgesagt hätte, dass wir wahrscheinlich aufgestiegen wären, wenn man sich nicht getrennt hätte. Als ich die Nachricht gelesen habe, dass Daniel Thun bei Düsseldorf unterschrieben wird oder unterschrieben hat, war mir eigentlich klar, dass die sich sehr schnell retten werden. Das ist auch ein sehr guter Trainer, da kann ich auch zustimmen. Der vermittelt ja auch eine gewisse Ruhe. Das hat mir bei uns auch gut gefallen. Wie er auch einfach mit der gesamten Situation umgegangen ist. Das ist ja teilweise wie in so einem College-Film. Da kommt die Tune vor, wie der Basketballtrainer, der mit den schwierigsten Typen zurechtkommt und die auf die richtige Straße bringt. Das ist ein Trainer, dem würde ich zutrauen, jeden Verein quasi in der Liga zu halten. Der Düsseldorf-Kader hat auch eine gewisse Qualität, die er mir in der Saison eher unterperformt. Ich hatte sie sogar vor der Saison auf Platz 1 mutig getippt. Muss ich zugeben, was mittlerweile unangenehm ist, zuzugeben. Aber für mich war mit der Verpflichtung von Tune Düsseldorf quasi aus dem Abstiegskampf raus.
Na, dann hat sich das ja so bewahrheitet. Und das könnte sogar sein, ich bin mir gerade nicht genau sicher, dass ich vor Tune Düsseldorf auch sehr gut hatte. Nee, bei mir war es der 1. FC Nürnberg und Paderborn, die ich als Außenseiter vornehin getippt habe. Ja, aber meine Tippkünste in dieser Saison. Da bereiten wir den Mantel des Schweigens darüber und reden lieber über Hannover 96. 7 Punkte vorm Relegationsplatz. Da war es jetzt, glaube ich, sehr wichtig, Tobi, jetzt dieses Spiel in Unterzahl, das ich gerade angesprochen habe, gegen Düsseldorf nicht zu verlieren. Und damit dann wahrscheinlich auch den Klassenerhalt zu sichern. Oder hast du da ein Fragezeichen?
Nee, da habe ich gar kein Fragezeichen mehr. Was aber auch gar nicht unbedingt an der Qualität von Hannover liegt, sondern eher an der sehr schlechten Rückrunde von Dynamo Dresden. Die wir in der gesamten Rückrunde nur 7 Punkte geholt haben. Und jetzt sehe ich nicht, wie die die 7 Punkte auf Hannover noch in 4 Spielen aufholen sollen. Aber ja, Hannover ist auch so ein Verein, der eigentlich meiner Meinung nach mehr Perspektive hat als das, was sie quasi in den letzten Jahren jedes Mal auf dem Platz bringen können.
Also ich finde, Hannover ist irgendwie absolut durchschnittlich. Auch im Kader besetzt. Also ich würde eigentlich von der ganzen Mannschaft nur Ron-Robert Zieler rausgreifen. Das auch fast nur auf der Basis der beiden Spiele gegen Schalke, wo er wirklich Hannover im Spiel gehalten hat. Mir fehlt irgendwie bei Hannover grundsätzlich so ein gewisser Zauber, der diesen Verein interessant macht. Wahrscheinlich auch für Spieler von außerhalb. Zum Beispiel der Dimas, den sie ausgeliehen haben aus Feyenoord. Er hat gesagt, er will gerne im Ausland bleiben, aber nicht wirklich bei Hannover. Hannover-Fans hören wahrscheinlich auch nicht gerne. Von daher kann man Hannover eigentlich nur wünschen, dass die sich im Sommer hinsetzen und schauen, wie sie diese Mannschaft und diese Marke wieder interessant machen. Aber ich glaube, das wird nicht in der 3. Liga passieren müssen. Dafür ist der Abstand auf Dresden einfach zu groß.
Da würde ich mich gerne noch mal korrigieren von eben. Ich wollte jetzt auch nicht den Eindruck vermitteln, dass ich Hannover jetzt grundsätzlich irgendwo auf den ersten sechs Tabellen-Rängen sehe in der 2. Liga. Aber ich denke schon, dass grundsätzlich bei Hannover das Potenzial da ist, dass du jede Saison zumindestens Platz 8, 9, 10 erreichen musst. Also ich sehe eigentlich nicht, wie man bei der Konkurrenz teilweise in der 2. Liga so vom Gesamtkonstrukt unbedingt in den Abstiegskampf geraten müsste. Aber ja, da muss ich auch Dominik ein bisschen recht geben. Um Hannover weht echt so ein bisschen der Winddurchschnitt. Man wird diesen Gedanken quasi nicht los, selbst wenn sie mal eine etwas bessere Saison haben.
Auch wenn man sich anschaut, dass man so die... Ich wollte nur hinzufügen mit Durchschnitt. Also diese ganze Saison spiegelt Durchschnitt wieder. Also neun Siege, neun Unentschieden und dann halt die 12 Niederlagen. Aber es ist halt... Also Platz acht bis zehn, was du vorhin angesprochen hast, ist auch das, wo ich Hannover vor der Saison am ehesten gesehen hätte. Dementsprechend ist man schon überrascht, dass sie sich doch so tief wiederfinden in der Tabelle. Aber wie gesagt, wenn ich mir den Kader anschaue und auch das Spiel unter Dambrofsky, seitdem er da ist, das ist halt alles so... Das schreit halt so 0011. Klar, jetzt dieses 00 gegen Düsseldorf, das war ein Ausrufezeichen, wenn man so lange in Unterzahl war. Aber es gäbe sicherlich auch Mannschaften, die irgendwie dann zumindest nochmal den Willen gezeigt hätten, so jetzt zeigen wir es dem Gegner aber so richtig und holen uns sogar den Sieg im eigenen Stadion in Unterzahl. Und das Gefühl hatte ich bei dem Spiel überhaupt nicht. Ich war schon sehr darauf bedacht, komm, ein Punkt ist immer ein Einpunkt, der wird irgendwie für den Klassenerhalt reichen, dann schaut man halt nächstes Jahr weiter.
Ja, ich finde auch, über dem Verein schwebt auch so mit Martin Kind so eine dunkle Wolke, also ich kenne niemanden, der irgendwie positive Worte über ihn findet. Man hat ja auch das Gefühl, dass er teilweise......kennst also keine Vegetarierin. Ja, manchmal habe ich das Gefühl, und das von anderen auch schon gehört, dass er fast schon gegen den Verein arbeitet. Da kommen ja manchmal auch Aussagen, wo man sich echt fragt, wie kannst du das jetzt sagen in dieser Position über deinen eigenen Verein? Und wenn man sich jetzt auch seit Wochen, oder seitdem Zuschauer auch wieder da sein dürfen, sich dann mal in einer Konferenz das Hannover-Spiel anguckt, wie wenig Zuschauer da sind. Also, das versprüht alles auch wenig. Ja, Positives, sag ich mal, was so im Moment um den Club herum passiert. Zumindest war ein Eindruck von außen.
Ja, ehrlich gesagt habe ich dieses Gefühl auch. Also ihr nennt es den Hauch des Mittelmaßes. Ich rieche da schon einen leichten Verwesungsgeruch. Ich hoffe allerdings, dass ich mich da täusche. Also Hannover 96 immerhin scheint es mit dem Klassenerhalt zu passen. Und das trifft auch auf den SV Sandhausen zu. Und das liegt daran, dass Sandhausen quasi die umgekehrte Dynamo-Dresden-Rückrunde spielt. In der Rückrundentabelle liegt der SV Sandhausen auf Rang 4, hat nur 2x verloren. Einzig und allein Werder Bremen und Schalke 04 sind da besser oder gleich gut. Also absolut fantastische Rückrunde. 21 Punkte von 35 stand heute, hat Sandhausen in der Rückrunde geholt. Dominik, wir haben vorhin schon immer mal wieder über Sandhausen gesprochen. Unter anderem, weil sie es eben schaffen, dass die Großen bei ihnen Punkte liegen lassen. Man hat jetzt nur die besagten 2x verloren. Einmal mit 0 zu 1 gegen Rostock war das, glaube ich, und das andere war gegen Regensburg ein deutliches 0 zu 3. Was macht denn Sandhausen so stark, dass man eben so wenige... Man hat viele Unentschieden, aber man verliert eben einfach nicht. Warum kann man die nicht brechen?
Ich glaube, Sandhausen ist ja über die letzten Jahre auch der Inberift der 2. Liga geworden. Also eher so dieser Club musste in der 2. Liga sein. Aber ich muss sagen, ich finde, das ist genau das, was so ein Club ist, den ich in der 2. Liga auch sehen möchte. Das ist halt so SSV Reutlingen, FC Schweinfurt, LRA-Vibes, auch dieses ganze Stadion mit den verschiedenen Tribünen und so. Das macht irgendwie schon Bock. Und wenn man sich auch den Kader anschaut, der schon ziemlich klug zusammengestellt ist. Also man hat irgendwie Seufert und Sucu, die ja Erstliga-Erfahrungen haben mit Bielefeld. Man hat einen Testrot, der immer quasi zweistellig treffen kann im Laufe der Saison. Man hat Diekmeier als absoluten Führungsspieler, der auch, wenn man als Stürmer auf ihn zuläuft, was hermacht. Von daher glaube ich, dass viele Mannschaften nach Sandhausen reisen und denken, die drei Punkte haben wir sicher. Dann doch auf eine sehr kompakte, eingespielte Mannschaft treffen, die ganz genau wissen, wo ihr Platz ist. Das ist das untere Tabellendrittel, aber es ist das untere Tabellendrittel, das im Zweifelsfall nichts mit dem Abstieg zu tun hat. Das ist auch etwas, was der Verein über die Jahre kultiviert hat, was auch Alois Schwarz vielleicht dem einen oder anderen Spieler mitgegeben hat. Das ist einfach dieses Underdog-Gefühl. Ab in der Rückrunde reitet man auf dieser Welle. Ohne dass ich jetzt großartige Sympathien oder Verbindungen zum SV Sandhausen habe, aber ich muss schon sagen, wenn der Klub drin bleibt, nehme ich das mit Wohlwollen hin.
Da werden sie erleichtert aufatmen in Sandhausen. Tobi, hast du noch etwas zu ergänzen?
Wenig. Also ich wurde jetzt quasi schon perfekt zusammengefasst, was Sandhausen ausmacht. Also ja, sie sind einfach so der große Underdog der Liga. Und ich habe auch das Gefühl, das wird sich auch die nächsten Jahre nicht ändern. Aber was halt wirklich ganz wichtig ist, ist, dass die, wie Dominik schon gesagt hat, sie wissen einfach, wo ihr Platz ist. Da wird nicht groß geträumt und nicht groß erzählt. Da wird halt einfach gesagt, okay, wir tun jetzt alles daran, dass wir quasi alle großen Teams ärgern und dass wir gegen die Kleinen noch die wichtigen Punkte mitnehmen. Und dann wird da mit höchstem Einsatz und großem Willen das einfach alles untergeordnet. Und dann bleiben sie jedes Jahr drin. Und ich kann mich ja auch als HSV-Fan auch noch gut daran erinnern, dass die zu uns am 34. Spieltag in Volkspark kamen. Uns hätte ein Punkt gereicht und die gewinnen 5-1. Und für die die Party des Jahres, weil die sich sagen, boah, wir haben dem HSV das Bein gestellt. Und so ist auch das Gefühl, dass sie auch spielen, wenn sie auch die großen Teams gerade bei sich zu Hause haben. Da wissen sie auch, okay, es ist unangenehm, in Sandhausen zu spielen. Fühlt sich dann teilweise fast schon an, wie so ein DFB-Pokal-Spiel in der ersten Runde. Wenn man dann noch das Stadion vergleicht mit vielen anderen in der Liga. Also ja, die holen aus ihren Mitteln das Beste heraus. Also kann man eigentlich nur den Hut vorziehen.
Dann machen wir das an der Stelle auch. Und als Letztes habe ich da nur noch ein Quiz für euch. Tobi, du darfst dich daran versuchen. Was war am 12. Dezember des letzten Jahres?
Dezember.
Wir sind im Segment von Dynamo Dresden. Soll ich auflösen?
Der letzte Heimsieg?
Der letzte Sieg sogar. Es war der letzte Sieg. Das war am 17. Spieltag, 12. Dezember. Seitdem nur unentschieden oder verloren. Sieben Punkte geholt, da kann man sich auch ausrechnen. Also es waren sieben unentschieden. Und das ist eben der Grund, warum wir, anders als im Ausstiegskampf, im Abstiegskampf kaum noch Spannung haben. Sechs Punkte Rückstand hat Dresden schon. Man hat zwischendurch den Trainer gewechselt. Alexander Schmidt stand schon nach der Niederlage gegen Kiel zur Debatte. Ist durchaus umstritten gewesen. Nach einem 0-1 zu Hause gegen Darmstadt musste er dann gehen. Neuer Trainer wurde Gerino Capretti, vorher Trainer beim SC Valle. Tobi, kannst du mir erklären, warum so wenig auch mit diesem Trainerwechsel geklappt hat? Das Restprogramm war natürlich dann brutal. Also Capretti durfte gleich bei Werder ran gegen St. Pauli, gegen den 1. FC Nürnberg, Schalke 04. Eigentlich wäre jetzt mit Sandhausen und Kiel die Zeit gewesen, wo man vielleicht hätte anfangen müssen, Punkte zusammen. Aber irgendwie klappt es nicht bei Dresden.
Ja, so wirklich erklären kann ich mir das ehrlich gesagt auch nicht. Vor allem, ich habe einige Spiele gesehen, auch jetzt hier in der Rückrunde. Ich finde, in Bremen waren sie erstaunlich gut, haben dann halt verloren dort. Gegen St. Pauli zu Hause waren sie auch lange gut. Auch gegen den HSV zu Hause. Also die Spiele, die ich gesehen habe, waren auch gar nicht so schlecht. Deswegen war ich auch vor 2-3 Wochen selbst ein bisschen überrascht, als ich geguckt habe, ok, Dresden hat ja quasi gar nichts gewonnen. Oder hat halt auch nichts gewonnen in der Rückrunde. Ja, ganz schwierig. Ja, so wirklich erklären muss ich ehrlich sagen, kann ich das nicht.
Das ist ja auch in Ordnung, musst du ja nicht alles wissen. Vielleicht kann Dominik uns weiterhelfen. Wie ist dein Eindruck von Dynamo?
Ich muss sagen, ich finde Dynamo zeigt sich eigentlich unter Capretti schon spielerisch verbessert, aber es reicht dann halt immer nicht zum Sieg. Also Tobi hat das 1 zu 2 gegen Werder angesprochen, es gab ja auch ein 1 zu 2 gegen Schalke. Das sind halt alles knappe Ergebnisse. Also es fehlt gefühlt nicht viel zu einem Sieg, aber es fehlt halt immer was. Und ich frage mich, gerade mit Blick auf Capretti, ob es dann halt nicht irgendwie am Spielermaterial hapert. Capretti ist ja jemand, der für sehr hohes Anlaufen, für viel Intensität steht, für schnelles Umschaltspiel, für den vertikalen Ball statt den diagonalen. Also was der aus Pferl gemacht hat, ist auch aller Ehre wert. Und war auch ein Trainer, den ich, bevor er dann bei Dresden gelandet ist und bevor das auf Schalke mit Ramozes dahingegangen ist und ich dann eher von einer weiteren Zweitliga gesungen geträumt habe. Das war auf jeden Fall ein Typ, den ich auf der Liste hatte als möglichen Schalke-Zweitligatrainer, weil er einfach so einen klaren Plan hat. Und ich finde, man sieht diesen klaren Plan durchaus, aber es fehlt halt einfach dann immer irgendwie an dem Quäntchen. Und wahrscheinlich ist es dann einfach auch dieses negative Momentum, die die Psyche, dass man da halt dann einfach kein Erfolgserlebnis hat und dann eben dann auch so abrutscht. Also ich meine, weil bei Dresden geht es ja eigentlich nur noch darum, diesen Relegationsplatz zu halten, beziehungsweise, ja, also eigentlich ist man ja sogar festsementiert, mehr oder weniger auf Platz 16. Dann wird es halt spannend, weil Capretti ja auch nur ein, für die 2. Liga gültigen Vertrag hat. Also ob man sich dann dann nochmal zusammensetzt und sagt, naja, jetzt geht man doch in die 3. Liga mit ihm, weil er ist auf jeden Fall ein Trainer, der hohe Ambitionen hat. Und ich finde, der Schritt von ihm zu Dresden war auch klug gewählt. Also auf jeden Fall eine Liga höher, ein Club mit viel Tradition. Was ganz anderes als fair. Und ich habe jetzt so ein bisschen die Angst, dass er so der nächste Atterlei wird, der damals auch mit Lotte Ähnliches geschaffen hat und dann bei Bochum irgendwie gegen die Wand gefahren ist und seitdem im Profifußball keinen Nachweis mehr abgeben konnte. Und die Befürchtung habe ich bei Capretti auch, es wäre schade um ihn. Dementsprechend hoffe ich für Capretti, dass das doch noch klappt mit dem Klassenerhalt dann in der Relegation.
Letztlich ist es jetzt alles eine lange Vorbereitung auf die Relegation, obwohl Aue jetzt gewinnen konnte. Am Wochenende sind es immer noch sieben Punkte Vorsprung, die Dynamo Dresden hat bei noch vier ausstehenden Spielen. Wahrscheinlich wird es nur um diese zwei Spiele gehen gegen den Relegationsteilnehmer aus der 3. Liga. Da streiten sich allem anscheinend nach der 1. FC Kaiserslautern und Eintracht Braunschweig um diesen Platz, wobei da noch ein bisschen mehr zu spielen ist als in der 2. Liga. Also schauen wir uns das an. Da könnte ja ein Vorteil sein, dass er diese Liga mit Fahl ja auch schon ein bisschen beschnuppern durfte. Ihr zwei, das war ein sehr langer Kurzpass. Wir haben sogar meine großzügig gerechnete Zeit ein bisschen überschritten. Umso mehr danke ich euch beiden für eure Zeit, die ihr euch genommen habt. Und es gab ja auch wirklich einfach viel zu erzählen bei eurer beiden Vereine. Zum einen danke ich Dominik Slišković von T-Online, der Ad, JasamDominik, auf Twitter. Danke dir und ich bin gespannt, ob wir uns das nächste Mal vielleicht in einem Erstliga-Rasenfunk wiederhören.
Vielen Dank, Max, für die Einladung. Hat großen Spaß gemacht und Glück auf. Und dann hoffentlich nächstes Jahr in der 1.
Wir werden es genau beobachten. Und ebenso danke ich Tobias Kröger von transfermarkt.de, der Ad Tobias Kröger. Danke dir, Tobi, dass du mal wieder mit dabei warst und viel Spaß beim DFB-Pokal-Halbfinale. Und euch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, danke für eure Aufmerksamkeit. Das war Rasenfunk Kurzpass Nr. 202. Der Rasenfunk ist paywall, werbe- und sponsorenfrei. Wenn ihr uns unterstützen wollt, dann tut das bitte auf rasenfunk.de slash-supporters-club. Auch unsere Gäste profitieren davon. Sie bekommen ein kleines Honorar. Herzlichen Dank, wenn ihr das tun wollt. Ansonsten gibt es auf kiosk.rasenfunk.de noch eine schicke neue Rasenfunktasse. Und dann hören wir uns bald wieder hier an dieser Stelle. Bis dahin, bleibt gesund und macht es gut.